good evening members um welcome to this
evening's meeting of northwest
planning um
yeah we have some chairman's notices um
all the usual ones uh fire our escape
here
you are being recorded um and by being
in the meeting you are giving your
permission to be recorded
to be included in the recording we are
being live streamed on zoom as well as
recorded
oh and please be careful of the
different levels of flooring in the
chain
please bear with me obviously i have a
certain competition which i will try to
get through the business but actually
the welfare of officers and members is
primary
my name is councillor matty thompson i'm
the chairman of this committee
members we're now working with the set
up for the meeting as grader council on
the second september
most aspects are back to the precoded
normal however some people will choose
to wear a mask or take other measures
and i would ask you to respect that
please
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
referencing a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers
please keep your contributions as clear
and concise as possible and ensure your
microphones remain off when you are not
speaking that is important for the live
stream
right apologies for absence item two um
can you apologize for absence please
thank you chairman yes we have received
apologies from councillor durham and
councillor jarvis thank you
right item 3 is the minutes of the
previous meeting it's recommended that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
8th of september found on pages to 10
are approved as a true and accurate
record i so move do i have a second for
that motion please that would be
councillor fleming just beat you to it
does any member wish to raise any matter
of accuracy would you indicate if you
wish to speak i am taking them as red i
do normally say that but
okay may we agree those by set please
okay thank you very much right
declarations of interest i'll read this
out to disclose the existence and nature
of any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
dialed to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded they're
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise through the
meeting
right oh i've got a selection i noticed
this side first so i'll go to council
keys
really remote chairman i've got a
non-pecune industry in interest sorry
which i think majority of us have here i
do did know the late council of rodney
bass and i did sit on sat on great shot
on paris council up until he's passing
and i did various
projects with him on lighting beacons
and
road closures and bits and pieces over
my time on great john paris council
thank you i think perhaps a general note
that
pretty much all members no yeah because
it doesn't really count as an
interesting yeah uh but counterweight
thank you
non-pecuniary interest um i've worked
with them i had the agent for
application uh
210824 has done work for us but again
it's nothing to do with his application
it's just a uh non-pecuniary interest
for thank you uh who next council
fleming
thank you chairman um a number query as
a member of essex county council who are
consultees for all the agenda items and
also non-pecuniary for agenda item five
as i know the parties involved so i
won't speak and i won't vote thank you
thank you very much did i see your hand
counselor
uh yeah so uh a gender item seven
uh again my family and the bus family
are being that know each other that's
very similar to council of the keys but
i think that
that applies to me is yeah
i did excuse me i'm sorry chairman and
the same
for me as with uh right councilman
thank you i think i'd be surprised if we
didn't to be honest
right we moved to item five which is our
first planning application uh it's found
on pages 11 to 39. uh there is um oh
sorry cancer
council morris
councillor barnes barts call me question
chrissy yes yeah for the benefit of any
applicant who's put forward an
application tonight yes
i really think it's yeah it would be
fair
during the agenda items if that you
didn't have a commentary and also
it would be fair to the officers as well
if you're not talking when they're doing
their presentation if you could please
do you know what regions that is okay
scientific standing
[Music]
your behavior counselor
is unacceptable
if it continues
you will have disrupted the meeting you
will have disrupted people's right to
have their applications heard
and i will stop the meeting
i will stop the meeting if you prevent
the democratic process taking place
and you will have done that not anyone
else and now i'm going to go on to item
you're annoyed
yeah i was just prepared to shut up but
now now you're also saying
i'm white
it's not me causing the scene
i'm grateful sorry could you turn your
microphone off please
i am grateful for council councillor
because he is one of the few you seem to
listen to yes because he's a good man
unlike you
well no i'm certainly not a good man
thank you moving on um
we don't have any members of the public
here thank goodness for that
we do have a presentation from miss
bowles ms bowles would you carry on
please sorry sorry richard thank you
chair she just dared me really but it's
a challenge now
but
it's my meeting i'm asking you to shut
up i know you don't care what i think
but this is the democratic process
i know you want
but i don't really care but i do care
for the applicants for the officers and
the members members i only need one hand
to go up and i'll say i'll call i've
said that i'll shut up for the
applicants but you keep jabbering on
don't you
if you be quiet maybe i'll be quiet
because i've already said i'll i will
show some respect
for the applicants i always was gonna
that's why i'm getting this done at the
start of the meeting before the
applications come
now if you can button here
you could just button it thank you
thank you chair
so we've got the golf driving range and
vernon road in wood and mortimer
i do have a verbal update before i start
the presentation
and the applicant did request if the
application could be deferred to the
next northwest area committee however
there are no considerations that have
been brought to the officer's attention
or any considerations that would
materially affect the report being
considered by the planning committee
tonight
therefore it's considered reasonable for
the determination of the application to
proceed
so outline planning permission with a
matter of access for consideration is
sought for the demolition of the
building and replacement of the driving
range and pitch and park with a 20 with
25 new one and two bedroom single storey
dwellings
public open space and an equipped play
area
the application is a resubmission of a
previously refused scheme
the amendments to the scheme include the
layout of the internal access track
the indicative layout of the dwellings
and previously the proposed bungalows
were designed to suit retired disabled
people
and would have been marketed solely to
the residents of the district for an
agreed period prior to being advertised
on the open market
whilst it stated that the dwellings
would remain suitable for retired
disabled people they would not be
specifically marketed as such
in addition the council's policy
position has changed as the council can
no longer demonstrate a five-year
housing land supply
and the local housing needs assessment
has been updated
onto the presentation we've
sorry
i've got the location plan
or you can see the existing building
towards the front of the site
and then the
driving range and the
golf course
we've got this existing elevation roof
and floor plans of the building
currently occupying the site
and we've got an indicative layout
access is a matter for consideration the
existing access point would be retained
and the internal roads and paths would
be included in the matter of access
as set out in paragraph 3.1.8 of the
report as you can see the residential
development is indicatively indicatively
shown on the western side of the site
and the eastern side of the site
is shown
as a area of public open space
containing a children's play area public
car parking
and a treatment plant and
and surface water basin to the rear of
the eastern side
we've got indicative front elevation
plans and floor plans
and they aren't scale and were contained
in the design and access statement
and but the dwellings shown on the left
are a pair of one bed detached bungalows
and the dwelling shown on the right is a
detached two bed bungalow
and then we have photographs to the
front of the site
and photographs is the
parking area along the top
and then within the site along the
bottom
and the photographs of the golfing
range of course
having taken all the material planning
considerations into account it's not
considered the changes to the scheme or
council's policy position have overcome
the previous
concerns raised the application site is
located in an unsustainable location
where future occupiers of the proposed
dwellings would be heavily reliant on
public transport private transport sorry
and the proposed development would
fundamentally alter the open character
of the southwestern edge of the village
and we've failed to provide visual
enhancement to the wider rural locality
in addition the proposal would result in
the unjustified loss for employment use
community facility tourism facility and
sports and leisure facility it's not
been satisfact satisfactorily justified
or evidence that the loss of this
important and beneficial use complies
with the criteria set out in the
relevant policies
and lastly
a completed legal agreement um in the
absence of a completed legal agreement
the development makes no contribution
for affordable housing
rams nhs services the management and
maintenance of public open space and
would fail to secure the provision for
residential travel packs therefore the
application is recommended for refusal
thank you chair thank you
um
right members does anyone have any
questions would you like to just start
the discussion and then perhaps we'll
naturally
reach a proposal counselor please follow
by council right please
i do feel
a bit sorry for the applicant today as
both his ward members
are not here and i think we'll all agree
that both councillor durham and
councillor jarvis always have a great
deal to say about
their um applications
in their awards now i i've looked and
brought in the book today because i
couldn't find any is the golf course
itself well the putting range the
greenery is that classed as brownfield
or is it just the car part b brownfield
um three chair as these sites in a
beneficial use and it's currently being
used it wouldn't be considered to be
brownfield land at this point
the car park wood but not the driving
range the grass area or none of it none
of it because the car parks attached to
the use
oh no oh that's some that's all i have
to say thank you
thank you very much a similar question
so if they closed the golf course
tomorrow it would be classed as
brownfield but because it's in use it's
not brownfield even though it's got
bits concreted over in buildings if i
understood that correctly
well you're looking at that one um
[Music]
if
we mr johnson yeah okay i'll let me
students and google that one okay it's
just just a curiosity that was just
listening to it that's interesting um
because i i thought that if you just
built on commercial use buildings or it
was automatically brown for better so i
could i could all be wrong on that one
and
car parking um
if we were mindful to approve could we
put a condition on there were two or
three car parking spaces per bungalow
obviously you've got carers and nurses
and all sorts of other people going in
and
my biggest problem with these is not
enough parking i mean there was an
application i was against in north
ambridge um it did end up being built
because the other members passed it and
actually i was so wrong it's beautiful
absolutely and i should have approved it
right from day one so
that's why i'm probably not as negative
on bungalow estates as well and other
things um the other thing is um
is it as near to a bus stop as i think
it is um
because we had an application recently
that i voted against that was approved
committee which
for me had problems with flooding and
ecology but anyway that got approved as
reserve matters
is this the same distance from bus stops
i think that was about half a mile away
from a bus stop is this one similar or
is it further away i don't know just on
the sustainability i thought it had to
be within
half a mile or a mile of a bus stop and
i was i know the area very well but i'm
not sure whether either or is not a bus
stop
what i'm not sure is how often the buses
run and whether that's a material
consideration
retail
in respect to the bus stop it's set out
in 5.1.12
so it is zero point miles from the
application site but it the bus stop is
only serviced by the d1 and d2 buses
which
um provide an extremely limited service
to malden and mainland
that's actually they're quite good in
mainland i live in mainland
it's every day it's a seven day a week
service d1 and t2 i think it shut down a
bit on covid um
i don't know if it's picked up again or
not but it used to definitely absolutely
be seven day a week so maybe kobe is
still playing up but that's just an
observation but i do know that because i
live in mainland
thank you do you have any um answer
about
change of views
thanks chairman um this as as
ms bowles says this site wouldn't be
considered a brownfield site i mean if
we're looking at definitions
um a brownfield site is an area that has
been used before and tends to be disused
or derelict land
simply just sees in the use of a site
doesn't make it brownfield
so there is no consideration of this
site
being a brownfield site and then
notwithstanding that as the report sets
out and miss polls can answer by direct
reference of the relevant paragraphs
um if the a change of use is proposed um
there are requirements within the
development plan
that the applicant would need to satisfy
the report sets out that the applicant
has not submitted the relevant
um
information or evidence
that would satisfy the criteria within
the plant thank you
okay
thank you chair
um
in terms of the open space as well so it
is at the moment
that's not really accessible to the
public is it
with the open space that is being
provided that would actually give more
public access to open space so does that
not balance
in terms of favor of this application
that the space will be will be open to
public
and through youtube yeah i have
addressed that and that is a
i've addressed that in the report and it
is a benefit however
um it has been offset um and i believe
if you just give me a minute to get
to where i've mentioned that
yeah so within paragraph 5.2.5 it has
been noted and that it was highlighted
that there'd be public open space in the
play area but it's considered that it
would be offset by the loss of the
employment generator news sports and
leisure
facility community and tourism facility
thank you chair thanks as well so
there's that ying and yang really with
that isn't there so we're gaining on one
but losing with the other
um
my one of my concerns is is around the
density if this if this if the site if
there were less homes being built on
their site would that be more focused it
is quite dense at the moment in terms of
perhaps the proximity of the of the
houses to each other
if it was less than would that be more
faithful
um it's difficult to say without having
the plans and assessing what's in what's
in front of you and weighing up the
benefits of of that scheme so it would
be difficult to say at this point if a
less
dense scheme came in we'd look at it
favorably
in terms of its proximity
if we look at the first map
on on the power point
in terms of its proximity it is quite
close
to
existing houses
in terms of of where it is so
yeah to me
i know it's you know it goes back to the
old thing settlement
but it in terms of that it is quite
close to existing properties and yeah
it sort of borders those and it does
have a footpath that links into the
village i know you say in a report that
there isn't that there aren't that many
services in in wooden
but but there's houses there already so
i you know again not i've had this
debate with officers before about about
facilities and sustainability so the
fact that it is close to those those
existing properties does that count at
all in its favor
through chair um
that has been taken into account in the
assessment and accessibility
of it the presence of other existing
dwellings wouldn't justify or
necessarily justify another development
and i do stand by my assessment in my
report regarding the accessibility of
the site
thank you
my big concern about this particular
development
is around section 106 and the fact that
there doesn't seem to be any
contributions coming forward
and my other big concern with this
is there is no affordable housing
allocated so
at the moment they're all all the houses
none of them are allocated for
affordable is that correct
through utah no they are
um
they have
indicated a willingness to do affordable
units but the agreement hasn't been
forthcoming so we don't have a signed
legal agreement in front of us but they
have
they have said they're willing to
provide affordable units
being willing
is not good enough for me
so i i think if the applicant
provide that sort of information to it
or or bring forward with that sort of
information in an application
then that might change my view but at
the moment just being willing
to me is not good enough
and i think yeah my particular views is
therefore i agree with your
recommendation
thank you just to confirm that i've seen
reason refusal for
uh which sets out those matters it is
the fact that there is no legal
agreement
and willingness of itself
in a way doesn't really mean a great
deal in the planning world
council
yes thank you chad
that was what i was just saying about
the density of it really and also the
willingness
answered my question really willingness
on its own
isn't enough to
actually has to be
put forward but um
i mean if they could just thin it out a
little bit but would that have helped or
was it really
deeper than that um providing
more sort of social housing thank you
through your chair it
um
obviously there are four reasons for
refusal and it's not just the in the
visual impact or the density that's the
only issue so
there is deeper issues um
as
in my report as the assessment and
thinning it out wouldn't necessarily
although i couldn't
like definitively say but it wouldn't
necessarily overcome all the issues
thank you
thank you
anybody else i've just oh no so just to
re-emphasize again you know the the you
know the starting point of the
assessment is the plan
the plan provides protection
um for land which is in use um it also
provides the opportunity for people
where there's land not in use or land
that that is derelict this is a land in
use and then the report sets out that
no evidence has been submitted i mean
i'd be concerned if
because there is a proposal for housing
and
okay there isn't in this case but there
may be offer for affordable housing that
in itself is enough for a site to gain
planning permission
i mean if you logically talk that
assessment you can roll out to any sort
of site what about the justification
these are set up within the plan they
must satisfy these criteria and i think
the report clearly sets out that no
assessment um to provide evidence to the
country about the existing use its
viability etc has been submitted
um so that that's something we must not
lose sight of thank you chad
thank you
council morning yeah just one thing it
it does seem to be we've been through
this before a bit where if
it seems that if there's good employment
and
and using local labour it seems to be
they'd like to keep it that way rather
than
perhaps
um you know
do away with that and just put houses up
is that thinking as well thank you
that's a fair assessment would you agree
mr johnson
yes you know we take on board a whole
range of considerations yes thank you
yeah
but i mean the thing about the
affordable housing is that it's a
requirement it's one of our policies
it's not a bonus
extra
might
be a consideration
but the standard percentage is the
standard percentage and they would be
unlikely to get permission without at
least that much
um some members oh sorry council white
i'm sorry i mean uh thank you mom i mean
mine was
can we approve it
if we were mindful to with the condition
the affordable housing is put in or is
that not in our
gift
i think that's bridged too far myself mr
johnson no we we
we could not do that we have to deal
with the matter that's in front of us we
would need heads of terms at least yeah
sometimes we can leave the detail
and delegate that but
not starting from nowhere council
sherman uh so i would like to put
forward the recommendation that we go
for refusal as per the officer's
recommendation
thank you secondary
council all right council keys just beat
you councillor morley okay could we take
a vote on that please
their hands
i'd rather do a show of hands except for
councillor fleming who is
abstaining officer's recommendation to
refuse yeah
that's everyone except councillor
fleming's abstention that she already
told us about
okay thank you members right the next
one item
six is lanchington
uh again no public speakers not that
that's a surprise
here
um so could we have your report please
response
thank you chair
so planning permission is sought for a
single story rear extension
we've got the location plan
and the block plan which shows the
extension colored in red
we've got the existing floor plans
and
the proposed floor plans and roof plan
the existing elevations
and the proposed elevations
and there was a previous
single-story rear extension approved and
this extension proposed is only 0.6
meters deeper than the previously
approved extension
we've got photos to the front of the
site
um photosh which show the rear
extensions on the neighbouring
properties
and
views of the neighbor to the east
the proposed extension by reason of its
location scale and design would not harm
the appearance or character of the host
dwelling or locality
in addition the development does not
detrimentally impact the amenities of
adjoining or nearby residents the
provision of immunity space or car
parking therefore it is recommended for
approval thank you chair
thank you that was quick
uh yeah i'd like to put forward that we
recommend this for approval
[Laughter]
just to note for anyone who's listening
the only reason it's here it would
normally be delegated it's a member of
staff and a member of staff or a member
of the council's application has to be
agreed or otherwise has to be decided at
one level above where it normally would
be so can we have a show of hands on
that please
right that's unanimous um agree the
officer's recommendation to approve
thank you very much members and
item
seven uh
final planning application which is five
corners maypole road again no members of
the public so miss false please
thank you chair
so outline planning permission with the
matter of access for consideration
is sought for a new detached wedding
um here we've got the location plan with
the site outlined in red and
the
land within the applicant's ownership
outlined in blue
and we've got an aerial view which shows
the site in relation to the wider area
including the settlement boundary
and the green dots
if or circles that you see that shows
the services and facilities within wicca
bishops
sorry okay so we've got the indicative
site plan
um the
access is shown in blue and that is a
matter for consideration
and then we have photos of the site
so i've got the application site there
and the photos of the wider area
having regards to recent decisions taken
within the area the application site is
considered to be within a reasonably
accessible location
just beyond the settlement boundary of
wiccan bishops and is currently within
a residential use as garden land the
principle of a dwelling at the
application site is considered
acceptable given the location and
current residential use
whilst the application is outlined in
nature it is considered that a
development which is acceptable in terms
of visual impact impact on neighbouring
immunity
level of car parking provision and
private community space could be
achieved at the site therefore the
application is recommended for approval
thank you chair thank you
members
questions discussion
counselor keys please hey german i i
called the application in
and it's for approval but it's come to
committee because of
um
on can't get the terminology right
because i can't point could i ask hannah
yeah departure from the local player
from the local plan
i think we're all fully aware that
maypole road has been heavily
built up on either side as you go
through mersey homes are in the process
of just finishing
a big development a matter of a few
hundred yards just up the road
a few years ago
there was a new house built next door to
this one that was in for an application
on the left out opposite
well it's not millionaires row i suppose
you could
class it it's very big houses either
side of the road as you go in and out of
wicked bishops and yeah that's all i
have to say and i'm hoping to listen to
what other members of
councillor i'm sorry uh thank you madam
chairman i mentioned a query um it was
quite a big house um i went through the
slides quite quickly there is a gap for
like wheelbarrows and bins and things
the back garden isn't there i just it
went past quite fast so i didn't
actually get to see it and i just wanted
to make sure there was a way
of getting into the back garden because
some of these big houses they don't have
adequate access
through your chair um the application is
outline
so the width of the dwelling isn't
um confirmed at this point and we have
actually um
you know that's right there is there is
that that's the photo i wanted and even
though it's indicative there is a um
space both sides of the house to get
into the back garden because my pet hate
is when um
you can't actually get the bins in and
out or anything like that so no that's
that's good that's all i wanted to see
thank you thank you
anybody
sorry just just just to be clear though
though that that's
not really a consideration at this point
in time
because it is indicative
and as um as ms bowles pointed out there
is an informative to just
remind the applicant uh that that
notwithstanding account the officer's
recommendation
um the design of the building there just
gives an idea of what could be put on
the site
all the other bits and pieces where this
to be supported would be what we'd
consider under a detailed application
okay
can we take a vote on that please those
in favor
okay that's unanimous again um thank you
very much members um
you'll be delighted to hear that
the next item is items of business the
chairman has agreed are urgent and there
are none
so i close the meeting at
805
thank you very much members and officers
if you could leave using this store i
think that's still